hello everyone and welcome to the first
game of the second day of the aimcheese
us rapid knockouts it's young shirt of
duda versus magnus carlsen yesterday
magnus won their match by winning two
games and drawing one and now uh duda
has to bounce back to force tie breaks
and this is the first game like i said
uh let's check it out it's quite an
impressive one so do that with the white
pieces opens with e4 we have e5 by
magnus knight to f3 knight to c6 and the
bishop to b5 do that goes for the royal
opus
we have knight to f6 and d3 uh so the
berlin defense is on the board we have
bishop to c5 uh and now bishop captures
on c6 d captures in knight b to d2
we have bishop to g4 magnus develops the
bishop by pinning the knight with h3 and
now bishop to h5 with g4 by duda bishop
to g6 and now
knight to b3 attacking the bishop here
and also both knights will now
serve as nice support if white ever
wants to execute d4 so bishop back to d6
we have bishop to g5 and now h6 also
attacking white's bishop bishop to h4
and now uh you could play
a lot of things here for example you
could just castle both players could
just castle but magnus continues with
this very interesting h5 it's not a new
move it has been played before and now
you're challenging uh white's g for pawn
so here uh white plays rook to g1 uh we
have h capture g for h captures and
queen to e7 and now there is one game in
the database where bishop the g5 was
played but here duda plays queen to e2
he prepares castle's queen side and it
is not as of move 14 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how
magnus continues uh he has to decide
whether to keep the king in the center
of the board maybe he will castle king
side although very unlikely or he will
also castle queen side
this is what he does we have castle's
queen side by both players and now queen
to e6 uh a useful move the queen will be
uh much stronger on this diagonal if the
knight ever moves you can maybe even
pick up the a2 pawn so king to b1 of
course black is ready for this and now
rook d to e8 if white ever executes this
d4 idea then you can just capture and
your rook queen and bishop and knight
will be ready to
to pick up d for pawn so here we have
rook to g3 the rook will maybe also have
some use here on the
third rank you can shift it to the e3
you can play d4 maybe shift it into the
attack at some point uh we'll see we
have knight to d7 by magnus he wants to
play f6 and shift the bishop over to f7
so bishop to g5 this bishop also isn't
doing all that much now here as it's
only defended by the knight so this
knight can move otherwise you're going
to lose the bishop so bishop to g5 and
now f6 we have bishop back to e3
and now bishop to f7 if the knight now
moves of course we can capture here and
we don't really have to worry about uh
white capturing this spawn uh if you
capture it then we can simply trap the
the bishop with b6 that's not really
what you want to do so after bishop to
f7 we have c4 uh now it's uh it stops
the queen and bishop battery here from
uh always honing in on that a2 pawn
but it leaves the weak d3 pawn so maybe
that's also something white will have to
worry about but the duda prepared for
the rook is already defending from g3
from d1 uh it's uh sufficiently defended
so here we have b6 by magnus uh and now
comes knight f2d2
uh and magnus plays g5 now grabbing more
or more space here on the king's side
and only now uh does duda play d4 and
this is now uh this is now a great move
uh as the magnus's c6 pawn is not
defended so here magnus captures on d4
we have knight captures attacking the
queen and the c6 pawn and now queen to
e5 we have knight captures on c6 queen
to e6 and now rook g back to g1
we have king to b7 forcing dude as
knight away from c6 and knight back to
d4 attacking the queen and queen back to
e5 so whether this was a sacrifice or
did magnus just blunder the c6 pawn i
have no idea but it uh does appear that
black has a counter play for uh
white spanning so many moves with the
knight uh we have queen uh knights the
f5 now this is an excellent square for
the knight the other knight might find
its way some someday on d5 and that
would be two awesomely placed knights uh
we have bishop to see five the knight
attacks the bishop here so bishop c5
challenging white's bishop here uh and
now f3 strengthening the e4 and g4 pawns
uh we have bishop captures uh knight
captures on e3 and now knight to c5 so
for the moment uh black isn't really
feeling the absence of that one pawn uh
and now duda has to continue uh with
something like rook to h1 or maybe
knights to d5 then trying to bring the
other knight over maybe to f5 or maybe
uh the other knight also to e3 to have
both knights eyeing that uh
d5 and f5 squares so that's what duda
should be doing however he played king
to a1 and this uh
although it seems like the king is safer
on a1 it's uh it's really not here
magnus plays rook to d8 uh and now you
don't really have time to go for knight
to d5 like on the previous move if you
try knight to d5 now then magnus plays
rook to h2 and now the queen is attacked
you can play something like rook to g2
now comes knight to a4 we're threatening
checkmate on b2 uh and after a move like
rook to b1 we can capture here for
example captures captures and now play
c6 we chase away this knight knight to
e3 and now queen d4 with a double attack
on the knight here and after the knight
finally moves now we pick up the pawn
captures captures and after queen
captures the black equalizes in material
but his position is uh better as the
well white king uh is really really in a
terrible situation here black controls
the uh the the d file with the rook and
uh black
it will be hard for white to defend here
so instead after rook to d8 we have
knight d to f1 by duda and now uh magnus
continues with a5 uh we have rook
captures on d8 rook captures on d8 and
now comes knight to g3 uh preparing to
bring this knight here and this knight
here but the position is now lost for
for duda but it's not easy to spot this
move it's a really
a truly an elusive idea so feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
magnus while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that the
king on a1 is truly terribly placed and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's a4 yes it's always great
when the winning move is a pawn move uh
and now a3 is coming the b pawn cannot
move the b pawn is pinned and it's uh
well just uh just an entire mess and
maybe in some lines even like the b3
check can be played if characters
captures then the rook comes to a8 uh so
not a lot of things to do here if you
try and stop the pawn with a3 then
knight to b3 check just wins for example
king a2 rook comes to d2 the queen is
attacked we're threatening checkmate
this is completely winning now uh so
after this a4 uh duda wastes another
move playing king to b1 so first king a1
now king to b1 in a position where you
should not be wasting moves uh magnus
just continues with a3 so what can be
done here you could play b captures on
a3 yes but then we just play rook to d3
we can pick up the pawn uh and a white's
position will very soon you know just
collapse
uh so after this eighth remove uh
knights the d5 by duda trying to you
know have an active knight on d5 and
maybe block off this bishop maybe try
and stop the attack but now just c6 this
knight will not be remaining here and
there is no better square for the knight
so here knight back to e3 and now knight
to a4 magnus just brings the third
attacker to the v2 pawn and there's no
way of defending it now b3 is uh
well especially impossible because
knight to c3 check just picks up the
queen so after this knight to a4 we have
queen to c2 attacking the knight but
knight just captures on b2 uh in here
black is completely winning but this is
rapid chess of course duda will try
everything and anything so c5 trying to
open up the black king's position a
little bit but now rook to d3 attacking
the knight here
we have knight g to f5 defending this
night and now just b captures on c5
magnus says this is not a problem i'm
just going to capture a pawn here and
now duda tries rook to h1 maybe some
rook to h7 action is possible but the
queen to e6 now by magnus going after
this a2 pawn
we have knight to d5 blocking this other
than this
sacrifice you don't really have any
other option knight to d5 but magnus
happily captured this knight we have
captures uh uh on c5
on d5 we have queen captures on c5 now
uh and here uh d captures on e4 and
there's really nothing to be done here
so it was in this position that young
shisht of duda resigned the game uh as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
but
i'm um
you know this is online chess so uh
sometimes when i want to capture upon i
accidentally just you know push it
forward and if
magnus somehow did this then duda would
be completely winning for example knight
d6 check king has to move we're gonna
deliver another check queen to b6 check
and this would be checkmate now and it
wouldn't be the first time this happens
in online chess uh and to magnus so you
know it could have happened but it
didn't magnus successfully captured the
pawn he played the captures on e4
and then duda just resigned here as
there is well
uh no no hope of continuing this there's
uh uh you could continue with something
like queen to b5 check but we can easily
block this with queen to b6 and you
don't really have anything else this is
covered by the rook uh you can't really
trade you're down too much material so
whatever you try here is just hopeless
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank seth
hansen jessica ricovicious uh hayden
queenie uh aditya para para saharati and
christopher alexander sopa for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing the coverage of
this very nice event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day